so i'll show you one application
which is focused around the stock market
actually how to pick stocks
uh and i can tell you that i mean we did
a very
extensive study that showed that using
very simplistic trading strategy based
on sentiment
you can actually beat the s p 500 and
i'll talk about it
later um and in the healthcare
we'll i'll show you how you can analyze
a user forums and basically any textual
content to find relationships
between drugs symptoms diseases
etc so let's go in
this is actually a people that are
familiar with text mining
so we actually started the area of tax
money back in 95
wrote the first paper on text mining
uh and this is actually an article that
appeared about
a year ago in communications of the acm
and the interesting thing you know you
can actually monitor how many times
they download your article so usually
if it's like a good article they'll
download it like
four thousand times five thousand times
that's reasonable number for an article
so this article actually was downloaded
72 000 times
so it shows you how hot this area
is and i think really sentiment analysis
is growing
very fast and there are really tons of
applications what you can do with it in
almost any area
so as i said i'll start with a very
brief introduction
what is sentiment analysis just for the
benefit of the people that are not
familiar with
it and then we'll go into the two
specific applications
so the idea is really to study the
opinions and sentiments of
mostly people but it might be also when
an organization voices an opinion
about any type of entity and sometimes
instead of sentiment analysis it's
called also opinion mining
but basically it means the same thing
so analyzing text in general
is not an easy problem and you can do it
in many different ways
i can tell you that actually a lot of
the
commercial products that try to do
sentiment analysis in many cases
end up just counting positive and
negative words
that usually doesn't give accurate
results
and you can see why it's not really easy
and we'll talk about it
more later why it's not easy just to
work at the world level
you really need to understand the
semantics the context
in which something is written to
understand really the meaning and if
it's
positive or negative so you can see the
first sentence
definitely sounds positive but when you
add additional phrase
definitely it becomes mediocre you know
it's not negative but it's definitely
not a positive
sentiment so opinions you can get really
for
so many different things it can be from
call centers emails that you may get all
the crm
you get a lot of stuff from twitter
facebook
news articles blogs so today there is no
shortage
of opinions that people have and i think
everybody when they try to buy any
product on the internet they first go to
all different websites amazon just to
read what other people
say about the products and i know i
definitely do it and in many cases i
my purchase decisions are better because
i read the feedback
of what other people have to say about
it so this is why really sentiment is
extremely important and you definitely
want to analyze it
very accurately so
there are many different applications uh
and when when i talk about sentiment
i even take it to a little broader
context one of the interesting
applications that
we actually developed is an application
for a
standard and poor's so you know standard
pools is one of the main
rating agencies and they analyze
they basically give rating to any board
almost any bond
offering in the market and they wanted
to identify
risk factors within the company reports
so to identify the risk this is also
its type of a sentiment analysis not
that somebody
gave an opinion but you try to mine what
the company wrote in the mdna the
management
discussion and analysis and figure out
were the hidden risks
inside so this is why i view sentiment
analysis in a really a more broad
way where you try to identify all sorts
of
issues within textual documents
so let's take an example of a review and
see why
sentiment analysis can be extremely
tricky
so you can see this talks about an
iphone
and it talks about all sorts of features
of the iphone
like the touch screen the voice
and then it moves actually to talk about
a different product about the blackberry
so if you take the whole document as one
unit
and basically just come count how many
times you
have positive or sent a positive or
negative words
you'll definitely miss completely what's
written here here it's very positive
about the iphone pretty negative about
blackberry
and unless you know to identify the
entities then what sentiment refers to
each
entity you really get completely wrong
sentiment and i can tell you that a lot
of the
commercial products actually take the
whole thing if iphone is mentioned there
will count every possible sentiment that
is very even if it doesn't even refer
to iphone at all it refers to a totally
different
entity so this is
was really a very brief overview
of what is sentiment analysis and what
i'll do now
is i'll go into two applications that
will show you
a what can you do with sentiment
analysis in the real world
so we'll start by utilizing new sites
to do sentiment analysis of stocks
so we actually created a system called
the stock sonar you can actually
go to the web the stocks owner dot com
and you can play with it
and i'll show you basically what what
you do
with something like that so first let me
convince you
that you really need deep linguistic
analysis in order to identify
what is the positive and negative
sentiment about each
stock so let's take this sentence about
toyota so most of the words that
actually appear
in the sentence are positive right so if
you just
use a dictionary based approach and
count how many times
you have a positive word and how many
times you have a negative word you'll
decide
this is a positive sentence for toyota
obviously it's a horrible
sentence for toyota everybody remembers
the main
the big recall problem that they had
so the idea is you want to identify the
recall event
once you identify the recall event you
know that this is i mean a recall can
never be positive
so we know about all the problems that
toyota had all the problems the gm
keeps having with more and more recalls
so we definitely know that recall is the
bad thing you want to identify it
as an event and then all the other
positive things are not really positive
so let me explain you the architecture
of the system and this is a typical
architecture
of a sentiment analysis system
so the input to the system is basically
the ticker
yeah if you want to analyze citibank it
will be c bank of america bac et cetera
what we do is we then go to
five major sites three of them are hubs
google finance yahoo finance msn money
are the hubs so you know they don't have
their own content yeah finance has some
of its content
but google finance basically is just a
bunch of links
when you put the ticker you get links to
many different sites
so they don't have their own content you
actually have to go to any individual
site
and pull the content from the site
in addition to those three major hubs we
also use
a seeking alpha which is
a premier
financial blogging site
i can tell you that based on research
that we did
especially for small stocks it can be
that one article that is published on
seeking alpha
can give a really very strong movement
in the stock either up
or down
and the last one is benzinga which is
mostly for analyst
recommendations so we get the content
from
so basically i mentioned five sites but
since
three of them are hubs we're actually
talking about hundreds or sometimes even
thousands of financial sites that we are
visiting the first step is actually to
clean the html
because you don't want to use all the
advertisements all the related links so
there is a lot of garbage on the page
that you don't care about so i'll just
jump to explain this step
so here we actually built a machine
learning
system to train the system to recognize
what is
the relevant content so
the training is done visually we
basically analyze the dom tree
so we take the structure of the page and
based on the
analysis of the dom tree we can actually
i mean initially we just have to take 50
around 50 pages and just click
red or green red it means the whole
frame is not relevant
and usually it's like a zigzag because
you said the whole thing is not relevant
but this
is relevant but this inside is not
relevant so usually it will be like a
zigzag operation
and finally you'll basically mark all
the different frames
that are relevant after you marked all
of those for
50 different pages and it doesn't matter
from which sites it can be from any site
we actually did experiments
where we taught the system on a marathon
training
and tested it on subprime lending
totally different
uh domain still we managed to get over
97
f1 which is the harmonic average between
precision and recall
and that's because we don't utilize at
all the words
that are written inside so we are
totally content agnostic
we really analyze just the style
of the structure of the page and based
on that
we can actually learn what is important
and what is not important just based
based on those 50 pages and
from that we actually get just the
relevant
just the clean content now
we go to the next very important step
which is identifying for each entity
what is really the relevant text for
that entity
as i showed you before on the review on
the iphone
part of the review referred to the
iphone part of the review
refer to blackberry so you want to
identify within
the article what are really the
sentences sometimes
the phrases that are relevant to that
entity
that step usually is totally ignored and
it's extremely important we actually
showed
in a in a research that we just
finished that you improve
the accuracy from 23
when you actually do it in a very naive
way to
92 so it's really a huge difference
when you really do this relevance
analysis in a very careful way
this is also based on machine learning
it's actually based on a
conditional random fields so it's a
sequence classifier that is
able to identify very precisely
what is the relevant text for each
entity
and then after you know what is the
clean and relevant text
for each entity now you really start the
sentiment analysis so we use
three different algorithms
that basically utilize different types
of
content i mean they work at three
different levels
so we utilize let me actually jump to
slides
so the first and the most simple one is
the lexical based so there we actually
utilize
sentiment dictionaries actually in the
article that i showed you from
communications of the acm
where actually i listed the main
sentiment dictionaries that are
available
and we actually took all of them and
using
machine learning algorithms we found
what is the best
sentiment dictionary for the financial
industry definitely for each industry
you need to create
a different sentiment lexicon you cannot
have a generic
lexicon that will apply to all the
industries
it's very clear for instance a
usually when something rises in the
financial
uh market usually that's a good thing
but if your blood pressure pressure
arises usually that's a bad thing
so it's very contextual and you cannot
use the same
a sentiment lexicon for all the domains
you definitely have to do
a very serious customization in order to
use the right
dictionary the right lexicon for the
specific domain that you are working on
then there are all sorts of combination
rules
or patterns so i'll give you an example
the verb reduce the verb reduce by
itself
is a negative verb so it depends what is
the noun
that we are reducing if we are reducing
a forecast
then it's negative but if we are
reducing expenses
that's positive so if we'll try to
generalize it
forecast is a positive noun so we have
negative positive
that's negative expenses are negative
so we have negative negative and this is
why it's positive so basically
combination rules like that
would be in this area and we have a few
dozen
combination rules like that that
basically enable us
to just utilize small lexicons to
identify
the correct sentiment finally
there are the events and the events
we have over 70 different types
of business events that we can detect
by the way we learn the
specific events just by doing
unsupervised relation extraction from
the web
i mean the classic approach is actually
to utilize rules
but that takes way too much time so what
we do is we use machine learning
actually to do it
so you actually take the text you
identify what are the main entities that
are inside the text
and then you learn just by using a
parsing
of the sentence structure you learn what
are all the possible relationships
between the entities then after the
system generated so the system actually
generates the code for you
for every for detecting every possible
relationships between the entities
by the way the entity types you actually
have three
options how to ident to how to define
entities you can either use lexicons you
can use rules if you want to
define the entities or you can use a
again a crf
classifier you provide tagged xml
documents
and then the system will learn a crf
model to tag
new documents that it never saw before
so once you identified all those
different entities
you can actually learn all those
relationships and from that you can
actually
find the events so basically all those
events we didn't have to write a single
rule to
extract them very well all learned just
by utilizing a very large
financial corpus so this is
this step okay this is the step of the
sentiment analysis now
you want to score based on all the
sentiment analysis that you did you want
to score
the uh the document for that particular
stock
and the score would be between minus one
and one minus one it means basically
everything that was written about the
stock
is really bad one everything that was
written about the stock is really good
and there is not even one single bad
word
usually of course the score would be
somewhere in between
minus one and one you'll see the scores
very soon so after we did
this we actually utilize it's not that
we have only one document
in many cases we'll have thousands of
documents or sometimes millions of
documents
so we take everything into account
you can actually take into account who
wrote the article
what is the source so you can say you
know if something was published on
bloomberg
it's more important than some private
financial blog
that i'm not sure who wrote it so
definitely you can give different
importance to different sources
and also the time when it was published
is
extremely important there is a decaying
effect
so basically like a day later
after an article was published probably
it's a much less important
than it was the day it was published and
it really goes
exponentially down as you move from the
day of publication
so here are just some examples of what
we have in the lexicon
so there are over 8 000 words
for the financial lexicon things
like what you see here here are some
examples of the event based
that they were learned by the
unsupervised relation extraction
um and this is actually how the system
looks like
and you can see for each one you'll see
for each talk
it shows you what is the type of the
event
that happened if it's positive or
negative
for the company in addition you can
actually click to see the original
article and then it will highlight for
you
in red if it's a negative sentiment and
in green
if it's positive sentiment okay
now what can we do with it how can we
use it for trading
so here you can see for instance tiva
it's a very famous israeli a
pharmaceutical company a famous for the
copacean
um and
usually what we look for is actually so
let me first explain what are the three
lines that we see here so the green line
is the positive sentiment the red line
is the negative sentiment and the blue
line
is the stock price so what you can see
is we're looking for spikes in either of
the positive or the negative
sentiment if we see a spike and actually
the market is going down
usually that would be a buy opportunity
if we see a spike in the negative and
the market is going up that would be a
going short opportunity so
let me show you a few more examples a
mosaic
in the agriculture space you can see
very big jump in the positive sentiment
but the market didn't move at all
you see all the move actually happened
later
when you go to an mba program usually
they teach you in the finance class
that the market is efficient well it's
not always sufficient the idea is really
to try to identify all those
inefficiencies in the market and take
advantage of that
a sandisk also very similar to what we
saw before
this is for the negative side you can
see a general motors
so you can see again the market didn't
move even though there was a spike
and a few days later it actually started
to move down
a micron by the way you can see how much
time we are following
it now here it was six dollars
people that follow micron it's like over
32
or something like that so definitely
that was a very good peak of the system
a
cliff natural a this is actually my
favorite example for
a pair trading
macy's and jc penney so macy's
you can see was definitely positive here
and macy's actually is above 60 dollars
already so it's three times
from what you see here and jc penny on
the other hand is around
ten dollars it was even much less a few
months ago
so jeff definitely just by long going
long macy's
short jc penny you could have
done like six or eight times on your
money
a this is actually an example where you
can see the market reacted
immediately when the newsweek came out
so it's too late there's nothing that
you can do you move on
so this is the classic and usually
this is what will happen so if the
market really moves when the news is out
there is not much that you can do
this is a textbook example for monsanto
also in the agriculture business
and you can see really very nicely how
the system peaked
when actually there is a very long
downturn you can see that when the stock
actually started to move up the system
did not
pick it up we can take
only the information that we have in the
text
in many cases they might be that a
stock is becoming too cheap and then
some hedge funds or
other people decide that it's cheap
enough they want to go in
they there is no news that will justify
it
so the system basically picks only the
signal
that we get based on the text of course
any trader knows you cannot
do everything just based on one signal
you want to use many signals
technical analysis volume analysis etc
fundamental analysis so this is about
a the financial uh the financial sector
as i mentioned a very similar system
that we did for snp really monitors
every possible filing that gets to the
sec
and within 20 seconds from the filing
the analyst will get
a very detailed analysis what are all
the risks that were found
inside the report whether it's 10k thank
you etc
and actually now we're also rolling it
for
a spanish for the mexican
stock exchange let's move now to
the next a
application which is mining a
medical use of forums so
the process is very similar to what we
saw before we need to identify
what were interested to mine
so in this case we wanted to mine
diabetes
um user forums so we identified what are
the major diabetes
user forums and downloaded all the
messages from all the forums
then you need to clean it you need to
identify the units
in a user form you have threads you have
messages sentences so we need to do all
this analysis and then you want to
identify what are
all the main entities that you have
inside so the entities would be
drugs symptoms maybe names of doctors
so those are really the main entities
that you care about
and also you care about comparison
somebody will say
i prefer to use this drug over this drug
because
you know this drug gives me whatever
so this is the type of information that
basically we want to get out of it
those are the main forums for diabetes
that we
found and we basically downloaded all
the messages that
that we found here what you can do now
is you can actually draw the graphs you
can see all the graphs that show you
in this case the co-occurrences so in
this case it's not
semantic yet you basically just look
that two drugs will appear within the
same message usually if they would
appear
within the same there is some connection
but it's not as doesn't have to be a
semantic connection
we will show later that when we use
actually the semantic connections
we actually get more information out of
it
so now we can actually see what we can
do
when we are interested in drugs that are
taken together
so now you can see the graphs if there
is the line
it means that those two drugs were taken
uh together um
and basically
the width of the line also shows you
how many times they appear together
here you can see when people said that
they switched
from one to a to another
also the the width shows you how many
times people said that they switched
from one to another
and now you get to the side effects the
width here shows the lift the lift
basically represent what is the amount
of surprise
that we get when we use the drug
and we get the symptom so you can see
that there is a very strong connection
between baeta and
a runny nose
you can see that doesn't work actually
has the lift only of one which is
basically
just the common uh thing there is no
like
extra information that we got everything
that is above one it means that actually
we have
extra information
now you can take a few drugs and you can
see which side effects
are actually shared by multiple drugs
so you can really do a very nice market
market analysis just by looking at every
possible graph
that shows the connections between the
drugs and the symptoms
you can sorry you can also see
here the positive sentiments that we get
you can see that we have the lift
of 17.5 that baeta
helps with hunger it means that it's a
very significant
something that is extremely
statistically valid
uh based on all the analysis of the
forums
uh again you can do it in the context of
the network
and i'm just rushing to a so i think
i'll stop
here right and we'll take
a some questions i'll just
mention one last thing that we actually
did
we took a we have a database of 15 000
medical experts
and we are actually monitoring daily
what are those experts saying about any
of the drugs
with regard to efficacy tolerability
safety and cost so this is actually a
report that the pharmaceutical companies
are extremely interested
in getting and this is actually based
when we utilize
a google together with the text mining
and the sentiment analysis to generate
this report